bonjour à tous petite vidéo ensemble
tranquille ou chill fès camou j'aimerais
qu'on leur reviennent ensemble sur la
saison 2 le grand final de the boys je
ne vous cache pas avoir assez peu de
temps pour le moment avec le ranger geek
fait ce qui arrive là ce week-end et
puis j'ai des choses un petit peu perso
aussi donc c'est une vidéo un petit peu
plus light en terme de montage schyle
mais j'espère que ça au clair on va
parler des deux points clés très
important évidemment la vidéo va ce pôle
et la saison 2 donc vous êtes totalement
prévenu puis évidemment tout ce que je
vais vous dire provient de ma tête de
moi tout est subjectif on est parti
commençons avec stormfront car elle est
le point clé de cette saison de bon je
pense qu'il ya plus besoin de rappeler
les origines de stormfront mais là où
c'est très intéressant avec ce
personnage c'est qu'elle est toujours en
vie en fait et c'est totalement un fait
et les vivantes et n'oubliez jamais
cette règle dans les séries ou dans les
films si on voit pas une mort officielle
c'est que le personnage est toujours
vivant qu'il a de grandes chances qu'il
revienne pour moi ce temps fronton
reviendra forcément et pas de n'importe
quelle manière parce qu'en fait ce
temple fronte c'est alors c'est une
représentation de tort évidemment
et apparemment aussi un mix avec shazam
mais surtout elle partage beaucoup de
choses avec l'univers de star wars déjà
par rapport à sa tenue qui fêterait
impérial mais tout simplement en fait
les éclairs de la force comme palpatine
en gros
[Musique]
bref vous comprenez l'idée mais là où ça
a été pour moi
dans l'épisode final c'est que
stormfront ces faits carbonisés elle n'a
plus de cheveux comme giraille ah oui
effectivement
elle a perdu trois membres et il lui
reste que son bras gauche et vous savez
très certainement qui dans l'univers de
star wars
ces faits carbonisés et a perdu trois
membres excepté le bras gauche
anakin skywalker bien évidemment donc
voilà je reviens aux fêtes stormfront
partagent beaucoup avec anakin avec
l'univers de star wars en plus elle est
toujours vivante
alors est ce que pour la saison 3 ou
peut-être des saison prochaine il n'y
aurait pas un
un rapprochement à faire peut-être avec
l'idée d'une darse stormfront storefront
un petit peu beaucoup plus robotique
néanmoins le gros souci c'est qu'elle
est détenue sheva août certainement dans
une cellule comme celle où était
starlight donc c'est à méditer mais
surtout en fait le problème c'est que
qui souhaiteraient financer un retour de
stormfront enfin bref la soigner lui
faire des prothèses et c'est quoi car au
final ce temps le front tu es devenu
l'ennemi commun en très peu de temps
edgar voulait la supprimer butcher et
son équipe va évidemment même les sept
ne l'aimé pas trop
et puis même le homeland heures étaient
obligés de se plier au final et puis
rien n'est plus important que la
popularité pour le glandeur bref j'aime
est donc peut-être l'idée de victoria
neumann et oui victoria naumann la
députée anti vote qui est la plus grosse
surprise de cette fin de saison
c'est elle qui faisait exploser les
têtes là et il ya vraiment beaucoup de
choses à dire sur elle tout d'abord bon
son inspiration n'est pas non plus
incroyables mais bon ça a le mérite
d'exister
c'est que victoria man est une
inspiration dans les comics d'un homme
du nom de vic naumann victor me semble
sauf que la particularité c'est que ce
dernier dans les comics n'a pas de super
pouvoirs néanmoins il réussira à finir
il me semble genre vice-président ou
président des états unis
enfin bref le truc c'est qu'on est assez
libre avec victoria naumann car on
s'éloigne beaucoup de ses origines et
justement j'aimerais revenir sur une
phrase du homeland heures qui pendant la
scène du tribunal disait que justement
il pensait très fortement que ce qu'ils
faisaient exploser et s était edgar le
seul à ne pas être présent là bas et je
vais pas vous mytho je pense qu'on a
tous pensé bien fort et surtout c'était
de la déduction est d'ailleurs agit
toujours dans l'ombre est quelqu'un de
très influent et surtout très
intelligent comme disait stormfront il
est très malin pour quelqu'un de son
espèce vu que c'est
qu'un simple humain enfin soi disant je
vous avoue que je ne serai pas très
étonné si au final les deux gars a des
pouvoirs bref pour en revenir à victoria
naumann je suis prêt à parier qu'elle a
un rapport avec edgar alors après
comment bien expliquer sa égard est un
petit peu comme palpatine
alors oui je sais j'ai déjà fait le
rapprochement avec stormfront mais
vraiment edgar est un petit peu comme le
chancelier quoi ils gâchent très bien
son jeu c'est lui qui envoie les
nouvelles menaces un petit peu dans
l'ombre sans que ça soit directement lui
il paraît presque même pour un mec sympa
avec les autres je veux dire le home
länder est la propriété des deux gares
et était la menace on va dire de la
saison une stormfront a été envoyé par
edgar et est la menace de la saison 2
donc pour moi ça me paraît plutôt assez
logique que victoria naumann du coup
semble être la menace de cette saison 3
et du coup qu'il y ait un lien avec
edgar par rapport à la liaison entre ces
deux personnages est pas elle est très
simple stan edgar est le leader de 20
août
et c'est tout bien que les ambitions de
l'entreprise soit très grande stillwell
voulait justement intégrer les super
héros dans l'armée et commencer à se
lier avec la politique et c'est avoir du
pouvoir mais ça n'a jamais abouti
et bien justement elle est là l'utilité
de victoriano man cette dernière est
très logiquement pour moi l'extension
d'edgar et donc de vote mais dans la
politique là où stan égard ne pourra pas
agir
victoria le pourra et la seule chose
dont vote ne peut rien faire et dépend
totalement et basse et la politique et
les choix d
leader quoi du président et dans la mise
en scène les bureaux de victoria s'ouvre
à la toute fin
comme pour dire ok le thème de la
politique sera dans la prochaine saison
et l'ouverture des bureaux et comme un
premier pas dans la politique
est ce que vous comprenez l'idée ça fait
un petit peu comme à la fin de la saison
une où on finit sur la découverte de
ryan qui est le fils du homeland heures
et qui au final est un sujet principal
de cette saison 2 et surtout il faut
repenser à la mort de suzanne renner et
dans la première victime avec
l'explosion de sa tête cela signifie que
cette dernière avait certainement
trouver la véritable menace de 20 août
des éléments cachés sur victoria naumann
également à la toute fin de saison
victoria tu le chef de l'église du
collectif église qui est réputée pour
être une sorte de banque d'informations
je vous rappelle qu'ils ont quand même
toute la vérité sur ce tome frontil
savez tout d'elle et c'est comme ça
qu'elle a plongé donc ils doivent savoir
du sale et font bien du marchandage je
pense très sincèrement que c'est pour ça
que victoria la tuer et surtout ce
dernier souhaitait plombé va août et
s'allier à victoria le fait que victoria
lui répondent en lui faisant exploser sa
tête démontre clairement qu'elle est en
désaccord avec lui et que du coup elle
va aider va août et donc edgar on va
finir sur le home länder et je vous
avoue que c'est compliqué parce que j'ai
vraiment envie de balancer sur lui et en
même temps je trouve qu'il n'ya pas
forcément grand chose à dire déjà je
kiffe leurs rapports entre puncheurs et
le homeland heures les deux se détestent
mais au final se ressemblent de bien des
manières et le paroxysme est vraiment
atteint à la fin de cette saison où ryan
qui est un petit peu le pont entre
puncheurs et homeland heures battu les
deux femmes importante dans la vie de
chacun donc rebecca port de churchill
terme fronde pour comme länder et c'est
à ce moment que cette démarcation se
fait quand ryan choisit finalement
butcher ce qui démontre bien qu'au final
même si les deux se ressemblent beaucoup
le choix de ryan démontre que berkshire
est quand même
bien plus bon entre guillemets que le
wonder fort bref je peux vous raconter
ma vie en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que blocher et ryan vont entretenir une
certaine relation votre shore a fait la
promesse à rebecca et là où c'est très
intéressant c'est que blocher par le
biais de ryan va très certainement
revoir son point de vue et son avis sur
les super héros qui ne sont pas tous
mauvais et caetera et que surtout comme
dans le cas de ryan bas pour beaucoup ce
sont aussi des victimes qui n'ont jamais
rien demandé qu'ils n'ont jamais voulu
leur pouvoir revenons au homeland heures
ce fdp est vraiment incroyable
anthony star fait un taf énorme
tellement énorme que je suis prêt à
parier là maintenant tout de suite que
la majorité d'entre vous regarde the
boys juste pour le homeland d'heure et
j'en parlais avec aero qui lui aussi
vous prépare de belles choses sur the
boys et bien pour moi la série
s'arrêtera quand le homeland heures sera
tombée
quand il aura tout perdu quand il sera
vaincu quoi et vraiment j'ai convaincu
de sa comment regarder the boys s'il
n'ya plus le homeland heures s'il n'ya
plus cette dualité entre lui et butcher
qui est aussi un père soit incroyable
donc voilà petit à petit le homeland
heures perd de plus en plus de choses et
arrivent petit à petit au craquage le
moment qu'on attend tous je pense le
jour où il deviendra une sorte de super
vilains qui va mettre à feu et à sang
amérique g2a dans la saison une le
online d'heure a été comme un prince
s'était stillwell qui gérait tout qu'y
subissaient les conséquences pour lui et
c'est dans la saison 2 il a fait la
découverte de son fils qu'il a perdu il
a perdu stormfront il a perdu en
popularité et ça c'est très important
il a perdu même au sein des sept
notamment mais qui est un très grand
pilier pour lui normalement donc voilà
puis on avance plus homeland heures est
isolé et perd en relation et ça c'est
très très dangereux homeland heures et
comme un gosse il a besoin d'être
encadré épaules et ordonnée et notamment
par une femme comme du coup stillwell ou
stormfront c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
stormfront est une femme dans la série
et non un homme comme dans les comics
pour faire avancer l'intrigué du
homeland heures tout en étant la
nouvelle menace la nouvelle méchante
enfin voilà comme le démontre la fin du
dernier épisode avec la presse ou tout
simplement les menaces de mails bas au
blender a besoin de sa popularité il a
besoin d'être aimé des gens d'être une
superstar et cetera
et le jour où tout ça s'arrêtera alors
je vous avoue que je n'ose pas imaginer
le budget d' amazon en explosion et en
litres de faux sang d'ailleurs petite
idée comme ça je vous avoue j'ai pas lu
les comics de the boys
mais si le homeland heures est une
parodie de superman peut-être qu'il y à
une kryptonite
quelque part c'est une kryptonite aux
composés v bref j'espère que cette
petite vidéo vous aura plu je peins
beaucoup je suis désolé mais en même
temps je trouve qu'il ya vraiment
beaucoup de choses à dire et je kiffe
tellement the boys j'espère que vous
aussi j'aimerais vous faire vraiment un
beau 3 théorie prochainement là sur la
chaîne concernant the boys
a vous de me dire si vous êtes emballé
après tout on n'a toujours pas résolu le
mystère de la mouche là qui volent de
temps en temps sur certains plans de la
série donc voila merci à tous n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner à la chaîne à me
suivre sur les réseaux a laissé un petit
pouce bleuets laisser un petit
commentaire puis bah j'espère voir
certains d'entre vous à angers ou
angélique reste allez c'était dargaud
rock et que le lionheart soit avec vous
[Musique]